se intensifican los combates en el este
de Ucrania cerca de bulevard Ciudad
industrial de la región de donetsk
soldados ucranianos en trincheras
defienden su territorio las tropas rusas
están a solo 800 metros
nos bombardean todo el tiempo a veces es
más intenso tal vez durante media hora
tal vez menos
Petro artillero lleva meses en su puesto
defiende el lado norte de la línea de
las trincheras donde los rusos intentan
abrirse paso aquí es donde podría
decidirse el destino del sur de Ucrania
pero faltan municiones para combatir a
los rusos
hace dos semanas un dron Ruso voló y
lanzó una granada f1 justo entre
nuestros grupos tuvimos que escondernos
bajo un tejado
mientras se convierte en humo en bahamut
los soldados ucranianos esperan ansiosos
los tanques prometidos por los aliados
occidentales una medida a la que Rusia
respondió lanzando varios misiles y
aviones no tripulados
como resultado del ataque el transporte
de armas y municiones a las zonas de
combate fue interrumpido incluida la
suministradas por los países de la otan
según Ucrania el bombardeo también causó
la muerte de decenas de civiles y dañó
edificios de apartamentos así como
escuelas en una ciudad de la provincia
de Don